[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mimi mathy
[Musique]
voilà je me suis perdue en fait du coup
je me suis dit on va combler à merci oui
ça va te l'avouer si moi je déconseille
musica
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors elle même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aie aie ça brasse et sur ma mère et non
pas branché sur la vie des gosses ça
mais en fait je fais du rp article ils
n'ont pas bronché sur ma vie n'ont pas
mangé basso ouais mais pas pour rien
adacore m'a dit ma vie là-bas c'est bien
et sur l'avenue de la mer c'est pas
possible
à
m
[Musique]
là
ben ali
[Musique]
chaque errant comme tout jeu c'est pas
mal de nice
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais
[Musique]
je retarde pas jeu
hélas
la clau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de là
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais
aucune
et
et merci